from the writer of traffic and Syriana
comes Doolittle Robert Downey jr. the
star of the judge this is meant to be a
prequel to the Eddie Murphy version
where he eventually turns into Eddie
yeah this has also got a little Tropic
Thunder universe in it yeah this is
gonna be good we already guys I know
we're late came out on Sunday I don't
even want to tell you why we didn't film
it we're filming it today hope you enjoy
let's get into this
[Music]
are you you
whoa
No
you can talk to animals
Oh
Oh No
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
he's on Welsh
[Music]
his name may be Doolittle but he's doing
a lot oh you've heard the end that's
right I'm not gonna lie John you should
please all right why isn't Yeti birth
you guys a no dr. Doolittle exist to
orbit Virgina I mean the January release
date is always something that stands out
to me I think in the past few years we
tend to get at least one good January
movie this looks like the kind of film
that I imagine might not be a great
movie but I think for what it wants to
achieve in terms of a family vibe and
having a heart I still think that I'm
probably gonna get emotional during this
I mean just that snippet when they're on
the ship and then the girl who plays the
gorilla you should know all these you
didn't do all your seems like it makes
them say yeah that's that moment I'm
like oh god it's gonna make me cry
I just know it's going right and you
know with everything we've been doing
with like photo-realistic animals from
Jungle Book to Lion King you know
homeward bound whatever the old
technology was like cats and dogs well
with a lot of this they're shooting it
in like a bright daylight yeah it looks
really like saturated we Ahlers so
there's gonna be moments where the
animals look really good at moments
where the animals don't look so good I
feel like this will be a fine movie well
yeah and I like that they went back and
they are making a kind of also
swashbuckling adventure it's a period
piece it's also a different I don't know
I mean this phase in Robert Downey jr.
his career is interesting to me because
this phase you know who else is in this
movie is like at least Tom Holland say I
know they're BFFs for El now but um yeah
it's interesting I think it'll be fun to
see Robert Downey jr.
character like this who seems like he's
got so much wandering so much good
nature I use this part of Robert Downey
jr. career where he's doing
I feel like mostly either blockbuster
scale or the occasional prestige pick I
think it'll be interesting to see
because me I kind of crave like a you
know performance from him again that
isn't like in a big shiny Technicolor
movie necessarily but I think he could
bring a dimension I'm not used to seeing
lately from him with this that one you
know makes me excited to see that I
picked up on he has some type of painful
background I son I didn't I didn't read
anything about it like he may be kind of
sad or lonely or something it looks like
he has some kind of loss and he's gone
on this journey yeah it's not like hey I
could talk to him yeah I get some grief
vibe behind it I don't know there's
something about this trailer that felt a
little melancholy yeah a lot and there's
the music has this kind of ethereal but
also very I don't know it just made me
feel the way I'm supposed to feel when
like something profound and yeah kind of
like the heart heavy or bittersweet is
happening yeah there's like the airy
quality that the music gives it and and
like slowing down a wonderful world
you'd always to me gives it kind of a I
don't know some kind of wistful vibe
sure sure sure
the production design is humongo january
release date kind of skeptical just want
to have fun after after seeing 1917 on
Christmas Day I kind of get Pam vibes
though that's my one oh little concern
in this world I could not in the same
stylistic wheelhouse but I almost feel
like greatest showmen a little bit in
some of the trappings of the setting
yeah
I mean if you pay close attention
there's that little moment to with
Antonio Banderas yeah looking like the
great the most interesting man in the
world
yeah what nuts is sort of living on an
island Spaniard donkey stud or something
like that yeah I imagine that's kinda
mean just by the way he's dressed and
musket kind of gun is enough he's gonna
start pelting and skinning all the
animals and selling their fur and
feathers for profit and then dr.
Doolittle has to beat the crap out of
him the writer of traffic wrote any
direct it I mean it is a dark shot like
there's almost nothing to allude to what
the villainous side of the story's gonna
be like but this is a pretty compelling
shot yeah is the only other famous
live-action actor I don't know that
little girl looks so familiar to me the
one at the beginning who came out she's
a girl from Twilight I don't
[Music]
I love child actors because like they do
you'll see like one or two of them just
like get tons of work for a couple years
right yeah Tom Holland is one of the
voices in here that's cool you just
can't let go of his mentor can II know
he's good he and and Downey jr. gonna be
collabing until Robert Downey nice and
then they're gonna make like a meta
real-life documentary about Tom Horn
grieving over death well he goes do a
European vacation rami malek post Oscar
win oh yeah following this up with the
voice of Chi Chi's we have the IMDB
Castle it's pulled up and it's just
their names but really no clue mister
which animal they are gonna pull the
Wikipedia but this just sounds more fun
too - is too - the toucan I'm assuming
so Mary Ann caught Lord yeah okay oh my
G are ya
Plimpton huh well hey that helped
elevate men in black that wasn't a
little international yeah that's the one
Selena Gomez mm-hmm I'm sure we'll be
excited to hear her voice she's
attractive and a great talent
John Cena as Yoshii Yoshii the gorilla
Oh is there a panda in this trailer whoa
what are you stereotyping I kind of
think that is white watch moist I mean
that would be a weird choice he's never
no I'm all for weird his name is Yoshi I
don't know I don't know what John Cena's
getting up to right now Octavia Spencer
dab dab huh and Emma Thompson ray
Fiennes I love all these heavy hitting
oscar-nominated or winning act let's get
a big dramatic past we're not gonna
combine this with a bunch of comedy
actors this is a movie but gravitas
let's get all these say hey I might
actually be better me Izzie normally
when you get these dying voice cast list
it's like funny none of these guys her
like except for Kumail that's funny but
even Kumail as far as comedians ago has
a lot of drama cred well guys are you
excited for Doolittle why don't you
leave a comment down below you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell which would do a lot
yes so far check I get it I get it cuz I
kind of made a similar joke oh did you
you did he's doing a lot earlier in the
video mm-hmm and we are going to give a
page from the day shout-out to a woman
named Anissa Oliver Anissa has started
her own YouTube channel recently folks
she's doing reactions on there as well
subscribe you guys should go check it
out if you like looking at cute girls
who like to react to trailers and such
that's the channel for you guys go over
to a nYSSA's channel right away hit the
subscribe button she's been a great
great friend to us she's in love with
John Humphrey doom whatever she can to
get his attention she's reacting to his
personal Facebook profile photos let's
go check it out as soon as you can
John's Facebook and this is you to
quality content SIA guests